Donc là, on va faire
tout le ménage.
Tout est bien rangé, là,
tout est bien classé.
La salle de bains… Oups,
mon fils a éteint la lumière.
Les clichés, ouh là,
il y en a beaucoup :
"t’es jeune maman, t’es maman pour la CAF",
ou "t’es maman mais t’es pas capable de t’en occuper",
"tu sors avec plusieurs garçons",
"t’as couché avec tellement de garçons dans ta vie,
alors, à 18 ans,
t’es tombée enceinte
et tu connais même pas
le papa".
Salut, c’est Juliette et eux, c’est Alison et Djülyan.
Je peux juste
te prendre en photo
pour mettre sur mon Snap ou...?
- Ouais, évidemment.
Elle va faire la star.
Alison pour Brut !
Alison, elle a 18 ans
et elle a deux enfants.
Son premier enfant,
Lyam, elle l’a eu à 15 ans
et son dernier, Djülyan,
est arrivé quand elle avait 17 ans.
J’ai l’impression qu’on
entend souvent parler
des clichés
sur les jeunes mamans.
Mais Alison, elle est loin
de ces clichés.
Pour moi, c’est
une “Wonder woman”
qui fait face à une vie pas simple avec une super énergie.
Un jour avant notre rencontre, elle a dû partir de chez sa mère
avec son deuxième enfant.
Depuis un petit moment,
les relations à la maison
étaient tendues, avec beaucoup de disputes entre mère et fille
et du coup, Alison
a préféré déménager
dans un logement social d’urgence
en attendant de trouver
son propre logement.
Je vais réchauffer
le pot de mon fils
au micro-ondes collectif
en bas.
Un petit pot semoule, tomates, aubergines.
Viens, on va manger.
On retourne
dans la chambre ?
Ah mais là,
on n’est pas du tout bien.
C’est pour ça
que ça m’embête,
il y a pas de table…
de table haute, plutôt,
de chaise haute.
Ici, c’est vraiment
camping, quoi,
faut pas t’attendre à du luxe.
Tu le changes là-bas, là,
sur le lit où tu dors pas.
Et puis c’est une douche,
donc tu le mets assis
dans la douche, mais...
enfin, il peut attraper froid
s’il y a pas d’eau
où il est assis…
enfin si il y a pas d’eau
au niveau des fesses, quoi,
enfin...
On peut pas boucher le trou.
Parce que je m’entendais plus avec ma mère
et ma mère, elle m’a… enfin…
elle a voulu mettre… enfin…
elle m’a mise dehors avec mon fils de dix mois donc...
j’ai dû partir trouver
une solution au plus vite,
pour pas dormir dehors
avec un enfant de dix mois.
Des fois, c’est pas toujours tout beau,
tout rose, hein.
Il y a des hauts,
il y a des bas,
il y a des hauts, il y a des bas…
Mais pour l’instant, ça va.
Ah bah… ça dépend
des périodes.
Des fois, t’as envie de t'endormir et de te dire
"c’est bon", t’as envie de tout lâcher et puis c’est bon,
partir loin
et puis tu dis "non, non".
Alison est avec
son copain depuis 5 ans
et c’est le papa de ses 2 enfants.
Pour l’instant, vous avez peut-être remarqué
qu’il n’y a qu’1 de ses 2 enfants avec elle…
Mais, j’y reviendrai
plus tard dans la vidéo.
Peu de temps après son deuxième accouchement,
son copain se fait
interpeller par la police
et est condamné
à 1 an de prison ferme
pour vol de voitures.
Du coup, Alison se retrouve
toute seule à tout gérer
sans aide financière,
ni de sa famille ni de son copain.
Chaque semaine,
elle lui rend visite au parloir
et lui apporte du linge propre
et des petits cadeaux
pour lui remonter le moral.
Alors… oui,
ça, c’est les affaires à papa.
Il y a Djadja & Dinaz,
Ninho.
Voilà… Des pulls
que maman, elle a lavés,
des T-shirts…
Enfin, basique, quoi.
Là, c’est tout ce qu’il a le droit.
Par semaine, je le vois…
deux fois par semaine.
Les parloirs, les vêtements
à laver, à ramener,
les mandats…
enfin, les envois d’argent.
Voila, je travaille
en même temps, c’est ça.
Alison est animatrice périscolaire,
elle s’occupe du déjeuner
des enfants à l’école.
Elle se prend en main
et fait tout pour créer les bases
d’une famille stable en attendant
la sortie de prison de son copain.
Il est 5h42 du matin,
on se prépare pour aller voir mon copain au parloir.
C’est dur.
Mon ange.
Ah, tu commences à avoir
un peu chaud, là.
Coucou.
Ah ! Coucou, mon amour.
Avec les transports
en commun,
on a une heure
et deux minutes.
Force !
Ça va faire… bah ça fait…
cinq mois.
Mais il l’a vu il y a
15 jours... 3 semaines
puisqu’il est sorti
en permission.
Mais il l’a vu vraiment
très vite fait, vraiment…
câlin, bisou et bye !
Il va jouer avec papa,
il va faire des câlins à papa.
On y va, go.
Hop ! Vite, vite, vite, vite, vite.
On y croit !
Merci.
On monte pour regarder
mon chéri de sa cellule.
Lui, il ne peut pas me voir parce que les murs,
ils sont... Bah là, on croit que c’est petit, mais à l’intérieur,
il y a encore des murs,
à l’intérieur,
donc il ne me voit pas.
Il y a que moi. Si lui, il se met en jaune ou en rouge,
on le voit bien,
mais lui, il peut pas nous voir.
Voilà : permis de visite,
pièce d’identité
et livret de famille,
parce que vu que j’ai mon fils avec moi, livret de famille.
Voilà, ça c’est pour réserver.
Bah… je vais essayer
de les mettre un peu plus tard,
parce que j’ai mis vraiment tôt.
Il y a pas, donc on va prendre 9h45. “Valider”.
- Un grand, s’il vous plaît.
- Merci beaucoup.
C’est parti, loulou ?
- Ça va ? Ça s'est bien passé ?
- Grave ! Je suis trop contente.
Ça m'a fait du bien,
je me sens, pfiou…
J’ai vu ma moitié,
tu vois ce que… Tu vois ?
Bah ça va, ils nous ont laissé vraiment du temps,
parce que le petit, il dormait, donc vraiment…
Merci Djülyan !
Tous les matins, Alison
dépose Djülyan à la crèche
et part travailler.
Mais ce matin-là, elle rend visite
à son premier fils,
qui a presque 3 ans.
Lyam est en famille
d’accueil depuis 1 an.
La justice a considéré que gérer deux enfants pour Alison,
c’était beaucoup à son âge
et vu son contexte familial.
Du coup, toutes les 2 semaines, Alison déjeune avec lui
pour passer du temps ensemble
et montrer qu’elle est en capacité
de le récupérer.
- Tu vas voir Lyam, ton deuxième fils ?
Non, mon premier.
Je vais voir mon premier,
qui a deux ans et demi,
qui va bientôt avoir trois ans,
qui est en famille d’accueil.
Le plus dur…
Non, franchement,
je suis tellement contente
de le voir, le plus dur,
c’est quand il…
Enfin, je sais qu’il y a 15 jours,
il a pleuré pour partir.
Mais vu que je l’ai vu samedi pour le coiffeur, donc ça va.
Mais sinon, ouais, quand
il part, il se met à hurler,
grosse crise,
il court dans les bras,
il écoute pas
la famille d’accueil.
Mon ange.
- Bon, bah à tout à l’heure !
- Oui, à tout à l’heure !
Il est où le bébé à maman ?
- C’est un petit cadeau
de maman ?
Est-ce que tu veux faire lui ?
Tu veux faire ça ?
Oui ?
Ou est-ce que tu veux
les petits poissons ?
- Oui !
- Ah oui !
Maman,
elle met le bleu où ?
- Là !
- Là ?
- Oui !
- J’écris quoi ? J’écris Lyam ?
- Papa !
- Papa ?
- Oui.
- Alors je vais essayer d'écrire…
- Papa.
- Ouais, t’as fait un "m"
un peu on dirait !
Ouais, c’est vrai, on dirait plutôt un "m".
- Oh, c’est papa !
- Oui, mon cœur !
Alors là, actuellement,
on est passé à deux heures
et demie de visite.
Et visite libre, sans personne autour de moi,
je peux aller au parc
avec mon fils,
je peux aller au magasin
avec mon fils.
Je ne suis pas surveillée,
donc ça fait grave plaisir.
Et puis là,
on attend un logement pour
qu’on puisse le récupérer définitivement, quoi.
On est repassé entre-temps devant le juge.
On m’a quand même fait
la petite phrase
qui me fait plaisir :
"Oui, on espère qu'en 2022, vous allez récupérer votre fils,
parce que franchement,
on voit que
vous vous en occupez bien, quoi.
Il n'y a pas de souci
à ce niveau-là."
Tu veux être footballeur ?
- Non !
- Basketteur ?
- Tu veux être quoi ?
- Maman Coco.
- Tu veux rester avec Coco ?
Un jour, tu partiras
de la famille.
Bah pas maintenant,
mais un jour,
tu reviendras chez maman !
Avec Djülyan, papa.
Non ? Oui ?
Bah oui !
- Papa !
- Avec papa, bah oui.
- Que papa ?
- Bien sûr ! Bien sûr.
C’est pas parce que
tu as 18 ans
que tu ne peux pas sortir
avec des copines.
Soit je le laisse à ma mère,
soit je le laisse à sa tante.
Bien sûr, des fois,
je sors avec mes copines,
même si c’est qu’une journée, même si c’est qu'une soirée
plus une nuit sans ton fils,
bien sûr que
tu peux gérer la vie de…
Tu peux être jeune maman
et jeune femme
aussi en même temps,
tu peux gérer les deux.
Coucou, mon amour !
- Comment ça s’est passé
avec papa ?
Tu racontes, Djülyan ?
Hein ?
C'était comment ? Hein ?
Il a vu papa et tout,
c’était trop bien.
Il l’a pris dans les bras,
il a joué !
- Ah ouais !
- Ouais, il a fait des câlins comme ça,
il l’a reconnu direct !
Dès que papa est arrivé, il a fait du quatre pattes jusqu'à lui
et après, il s’est endormi
sur papa tout au long
et puis ils nous ont laissé
1 heure 15 de parloir,
parce qu’il s’est endormi.
Ils nous ont laissé
15 minutes de plus.
- Ah bah ça va.
- Moi, je me suis levée
à 4h30-5h
pour le préparer, pour prendre le premier bus à 6h
pour aller jusqu'à Vezin.
Et puis là… Au revoir, déjà !
- Ah, il dit au revoir !
- Viens là, c'est bien maman
et puis là,
c'était vraiment bien au revoir !
OK, bah bisous, mon fils !
Coucou !
Ça va ?
- Mon bébé, mon bébé !
- Je t’ai manqué, avoue !
Ça s’est bien passé ?
- C'était trop bien !
Ça me manque, hein !
J’ai envie de pleurer,
mais il me manque de ouf.
Câlins, bisous,
il a pris son fils…
Ça fait 6 mois qu’il est là-bas
et c’est que hier qu’il a pu prendre son fils dans les bras.
Et une heure vite fait
en permission
quand il est sorti pour
du travail, mais voilà…
- Ta sœur, ça va?
- Elle a hâte d’accoucher, quoi.
- Elle accouche quand ?
- Normalement, c’est prévu entre le 24 et le 25 juillet.
- Dans même pas un mois…
Ah si, dans un mois et demi.
- Ma grande sœur, elle accouche de mon petit neveu.
- Trop bien, tu vas le pouponner encore.
Merci.
- Merci beaucoup.
Je vais faire une petite story.
- Ça va, il y a un filtre, c’est bon, t’es contente ?
- Grave !
Bon appétit !
- Merci, toi aussi.
Oh coucou !
Coucou, mon bébé !
Coucou, mon amour !
Coucou !
- Bah alors !
- Il a grandi, hein ?
- Wesh, il grandit trop vite, lui !
- Bon allez, bisous,
à tout à l’heure !
Ohhh, il me manque trop !
J’ai hâte d'être tout à l’heure.
Merci, au revoir !
Les journées d’Alison
sont méga remplies,
et encore, on n’a même pas tout vu.
Malgré les clichés qu’on peut entendre sur les jeunes mamans,
Alison les défie.
Elle travaille et gère les finances
de sa famille, cuisine, fait le ménage,
s’occupe du linge pour elle,
ses fils et son copain incarcéré,
rend visite à son copain en prison et à son enfant placé en famille d’accueil
et fait tout pour montrer qu’elle
est capable de le récupérer,
recherche activement un logement,
fait les courses
avec un budget restreint,
essaie de trouver
du temps pour ses amis…
et garde constamment
la pêche et un grand sourire.
Sans compter
les heures qu’elle passe
dans les transports en commun.
Eh bien, il faut !
Il faut !
Le plus dur,
c’est d'être
loin de son fils, déjà,
et loin de son compagnon,
parce que pour moi,
c’est un soutien,
donc tout ce que j’ai…
je l'évacue, comme ça,
il prend tout…
Mais c’est dur, t’as pas
une épaule
où tu peux t’appuyer, quoi.
Mon épaule n’est pas là !
Ma béquille n’est pas là !
Si j’avais pas eu mes enfants, à l'heure actuelle,
je ne sais même pas
où je serais.
Vraiment, je ne sais même pas si je saurais travailler,
je sais même pas si je serais en train de déconner, enfin,
vraiment, ça m’a changée,
parce qu'avant de tomber enceinte de mon premier,
j’étais en train de déconner
et dès que je suis tombée enceinte, ça a tout arrêté.
Ah bah, je les aime !
C’est ma vie ! C’est mes amoureux ! C’est mes…
C’est mes bébés !
C’est toute ma vie.
Pour l’instant, le futur est
incertain pour Alison.
Son but est de déménager
le plus rapidement possible
de son logement d’urgence.
Et en novembre, elle espère récupérer son deuxième fils,
Lyam.
Plutôt compliquée, parce que j’ai pas de logement, là,
je suis dans un hôtel,
compliquée, car mon fils,
il est en famille d’accueil
compliquée aussi, parce que
je suis loin de mon chéri.
Mais, prochainement,
ça va évoluer
et on espère vraiment que...
que du positif, quoi.
Merci d’avoir
regardé cette vidéo,
j'espère qu’elle vous a plu.
Si jamais vous avez
d’autres idées de sujet,
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer
un message sur Instagram.
J’assaye de lire
tous vos messages,
même si je n’arrive pas à répondre à tout le monde.
Et on se voit
à la prochaine vidéo.
Salut !
Subtitle to use, please
pay attention to the Red Grid